>> Will Sentance: Vì vậy, để tóm tắt giải pháp hai trở lại cốt lõi của mục tiêu ở đây.
Giống như tôi đã tặng những phần thưởng đó cho tất cả chúng ta, những thứ hấp dẫn.
Sử dụng chuỗi nguyên mẫu, sử dụng nguyên mẫu JavaScript hoặc
tính năng người dùng một và người dùng hai,
truy cập từ khi chúng được tạo bên trong trình tạo người dùng
với thứ tự để tạo mà cho đối tượng của họ một liên kết để sử dụng một cửa hàng chức năng.
Khi tôi chạy user one.increment và không tìm thấy nó,
chức năng gia tăng của người dùng một, tôi có hoảng sợ không?
Không, tôi hướng dẫn tham chiếu proto tại chuỗi nguyên mẫu cho người dùng
cửa hàng chức năng nơi tôi tìm thấy số tăng và tôi chạy nó, vấn đề với điều này?
Không có vấn đề, nó đẹp.
Đó là một loại Chiến tranh giữa các vì sao với bạn trong cuộc phỏng vấn nói với người phỏng vấn của bạn,
Tôi thích hơn vì tôi muốn kiểm soát chi tiết hơn đối với việc tôi viết
oxy mà tôi có xu hướng thử và làm theo cách tiếp cận này.
Và họ sẽ đi, họ sẽ nghĩ điều tồi tệ nhất.
Nhưng, đồng thời, chúng sẽ đi, thật ấn tượng.
Tôi nên nói rằng tôi đồng ý.
Họ sẽ đi, vâng, tôi cũng vậy.
Họ không nói là đúng cách, nó chắc chắn không chuẩn.
Và tôi sẽ không đề nghị bạn sử dụng cái này nhưng
nó sẽ trở thành câu trả lời cho những gì đang thực sự xảy ra
khi chúng tôi sử dụng cách tiêu chuẩn để đạt được cùng mục tiêu này.
Cuz theo cách tiêu chuẩn, giải pháp ba và bốn, ngày càng chỉ là giải pháp bốn,
đằng sau hậu trường đang làm tất cả những điều này ở đây.
Và điều đó có nghĩa là nếu bạn phải gỡ lỗi, bạn phải hiểu nó.
Điều đó có nghĩa là nếu bạn muốn phỏng vấn và trả lời câu hỏi thì từ khóa mới là gì
thực sự làm ở hậu trường, bạn phải biết tất cả những thứ này.
Và tôi sẽ nói điều này, nếu bạn đang viết,
nếu một khi bạn bắt đầu suy nghĩ theo mô hình này theo cách suy nghĩ này,
bạn bắt đầu cấu trúc mọi thứ bạn làm dưới dạng đối tượng chứa
dữ liệu liên quan đến tính năng đó và chức năng liên quan của nó.
Bạn đang giải quyết có người dùng và quản trị viên, người kiểm duyệt và các câu hỏi đố vui,
và bảng giải đấu, và thậm chí cả ứng dụng trò chơi.
Tất cả chỉ là một tập hợp dữ liệu liên quan đến
ngay cả bảng trò chơi,
kích thước của bảng trò chơi và sau đó là chức năng liên quan đến bảng trò chơi đó.
Tôi sử dụng một cái gì đó cho mọi thứ theo cách này.
Vì vậy, bạn bắt đầu viết rất nhiều hàm này để tạo ra một đối tượng,
đôi khi chỉ một đối tượng chỉ với một loại chức năng và
bạn chỉ có một trong số họ, bạn chỉ cần suy nghĩ theo cách này từ bây giờ.
Vì vậy, tôi đoán nếu bạn luôn tạo ra một vật thể nhỏ bên trong, luôn làm cho
kết nối với một kho các hàm, luôn trả về đối tượng đó giống như, tôi đoán vậy
có thể rất tốt nếu bạn có cách tự cứu mình trong suốt quá trình đó.
Nhưng cách này thì siêu tinh vi nhưng không chuẩn.
Vì vậy, bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thấy trong giải pháp ba cách tiêu chuẩn hơn
giới thiệu từ khóa, chúng là tất cả những gì tạo nên sự khó khăn, mới mẻ của nó.